الاهم وسيله هو اطلاق الصواريخ من شمال
قطاع غزه وبعد ساعات قليله من اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانه دمر 700 منصه اطلاق
صواريخ في قطاع غزه تعود المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اليوم لتطلق صواريخ من المنطقه
الشماليه من قطاع غزه وهذه المنطقه التي
تعرضت على مدى شهرين الماضيين الى اعنف
هجمات سواء بريه او بحريه من الزوارق
البحريه او او الجويه بطبيعه الحال او
الهجوم البري الذي استهدف في المرحله
الاولى منه المرحله الاولى كانت منذ بدايه
27 من اكتوبر استهدفت المناطق الشماليه من
قطاع غزه وتوغلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
كما نعلم في كل مناطق شمال قطاع غزه
واستهدفت المنطقه الشماليه وصلت الى وكان
الهدف بطبيعه الحال هذه المنطقه الرمال
المنطقه الغربيه ووصلت الى حيي التفاح
والدرج ودخلت حي الشجاعيه ودخلت جبالي
البلد ودخلت الشيخ رضوان ومخيم الشاطئ
طبعا وكل هذه المناطق دخلت بيت لاهيه
ودمرتها دخلت بيت حنون ودمرتها اذا
المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه مدينه غزه
محافظتي مدينه محافظتي غزه وشمال غزه
تعرضت لاعنف هجوم بري وبحري وجوي على مدى
ثلاثه شهور الماضيه ونحن على بعد اقل من
12 ع ساعه من دخول اليوم المئه لهذه
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتواصله
على قطاع غزه ت تعود المقاومه الفلسطينيه
اليوم لتطلق صواريخها من المنطقه الشماليه
في رساله واضحه للرد على قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي قالت بانها انتهت من
العمليات العسكريه في المنطقه الشماليه
وانها دمرت 700 منصه اطلاق صواريخ وقتلت
9000 من مقاتلي كتائب القسام في قطاع غزه
تعود المقاومه لتطلق صواريخها من هذه
المنطقه والهدف وفق ما اشار الياس هي
مستوطن نتيف عسرا نتيف ع سراه هذه
المستوطنه المحاذيه للسياج الفاصل بين
قطاع غزه واسرائيل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الان تتمركز بهذا الشكل تقريبا
في المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه دمرت كل
هذه المناطق كما ذكرنا بيت حنون بيت لاهيا
الع عطاطره دمرتها بشكل شبه كامل ولكن
المقاومه لا تزال تخوض معارك من المسافه
صفر وتطلق صواريخها من المنطقه الشماليه
من قطاع غزه اذا ما ذهبنا الى المنطقه
الجنوبيه من مدينه غزه اي اننا نتحدث عن
اقصى جنوب المناطق الشماليه نتحدث عن
منطقه الزيتون في هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه
اي ايضا لا تزال قوات الاحتلال تتمركز
فيها وتفصل تقطع مناطق الشماليه من قطاع
غزه ايه محافظتي غزه وشمال غزه تفصيلهم عن
المنطقه الوسطى والمنطقه الجنوبيه قوات
الاحتلال تتمركز في هذه النقاط والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه تخوض اشتباكات وتهجم على تهاجم
قوات الاحتلال المتمركزه في منطقه الزيتون
كما شاهدنا بفيديو سرايا القدس الذي نشرته
يوم امس المنطقه الوسطى تشهد تطورات نوعيه
خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه استهدافات
بالطيران للمنطقه الغربيه من منطقه دير
البلح القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتقدم
باتجاه دير البلح من المنطقه الشماليه اي
لاننا نتحدث عن
منطقتي المغازي والمصدر في هاتين
المنطقتين تتواجد قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تتقدم من هذه المنطقه الشماليه
باتجاه دير البلح ووصلت الى هاتين
النقطتين على مدخلي دير البلح رغم انها
كانت في المنطقه الجنوبيه من دير البلح قد
انسحبت بشكل لافت للنظر وهي المنطقه بين
دير البلح وخان يونس في هذه المنطقه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت قد تمركزت ل
خلال الاسابيع القليله الماضيه ولكنها
انسحبت خلال هذا الاسبوع اي قبل عده ايام
انسحبت من هذه المنطقه وتمركزت العمليات
العسكريه او التقدم حتى هذه اللحظه على
محور صلاح الدين من الجهه الشماليه
الشرقيه لدير البلح هذا يسحبنا للحديث عن
منطقه خانيونس اذ ان هذه المنطقه هي
المنطقه الفاصله بين دير البلح وخانيونس
انسحبت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من هذه
المنطقه من منطقه ابو هولي وشارع كيسوفيم
وشمال الق القراره بعد عمليات عسكريه
استمرت لعده اسابيع في القراره ولكنها لم
تحقق فيها اي انجاز عسكري اي انها كان
كانت تسعى للتقدم من القراره باتجاه مدينه
خان يونس عبر الزنه ولكنها لم تنجح في ذلك
فانسحبت من منطقه القراره قتب القسام
اليوم في بياناتها ركزت كثيرا على
عملياتها العسكريه في منطقه خانيونس رغم
ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لم تستطع حتى
الان الدخول الى قلب مدينه خانيونس
وتتمركز في الجهه الشرقيه من خانيونس عند
محور صلاح الدين كتائب القسام اكدت اليوم
بانها تخوض اشتباكات واسعه في المنطقه
الشرقيه من خانيونس مدينه خانيونس بطبيعه
الحال لان قوات الاحت الاسرائيلي وصلت من
هذه الجهه من جهه بن سهيلا وعبس والزناه
وتمركزت عند هاتين النقطتين في شرقي مدينه
خانيونس لان قوات الاحتلال حتى هذه اللحظه
لم تستطع التوغل داخل مدينه خان يونس
وتخوض معارك عنيفه وتتعرض لهجمات شديده من
قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في المنطقه
الشرقيه من مدينه خانيونس